in a local teaching district a
technology grant is available to
teachers in order to install a cluster
of four computers in their classroom
from the 6250 teachers in the district
250 were randomly selected and asked if
they felt that computers were an
essential teaching tool for their
classroom of those selected 142 teachers
142 teachers felt that the computers
were an essential we're an essential
teaching tool and then they asked us
calculate a 99% confidence interval for
the proportion of teachers who felt that
the computers are an essential teaching
tool so let's just think about the
entire population we weren't able to
survey all of them but the entire
population there were the entire
population some of them fall in the
bucket and we'll define that as one they
thought it was a good tool they thought
that the computers were a good tool and
we'll just define a zero value as a
teacher that says not good not good
and some proportion of the total of the
total teachers think that it is a good
learning tool so that proportion is P
and then the rest of them think it's a
bad learning tool so the rest of them
think it is a bad learning tool 1 - P we
have a Bernoulli distribution right over
here and we know that the mean of this
distribution or the expected value of
this distribution is actually going to
be P so it's actually going to be a
value it's neither 0 or 1 so not an
actual value that you could actually get
out of a teacher if you were to ask them
they cannot say something in between
good and not good they but the actual
expected value is something in between
it is it is P now what we do is we're
taking a sample of those 250 teachers
and we got that 142 felt that the
computers were an essential tool
teaching tool so we got so in our survey
so we had 250 250 sampled 250 sampled
and we got 142 said that it is good and
we'll say that this is a 1 so we got 142
ones or we sampled one 140
two times from this distribution and
then the rest of the times so what's
left over there's another 108 who said
that it's not good so 108 said not good
or you could view them as you are
sampling a zero right 108 plus 142 is
250 so what is our sample mean here our
sample mean here we have 1 times 142
times 142 plus 0 times 108 divided by
our total number of samples divided by
250 it is equal to 142 over 250 you
could even view this as the sample
proportion of teachers who thought that
the computers were a good teaching tool
now let me get a calculator out to
calculate this so we have 142 divided by
250 is equal to 0.5 6 8 so our sample
proportion is 0.568 or 56.8 percent
either one so 0 0.568 now let's also
figure out our sample variance because
we can use it later for building our
confidence interval our sample variance
here so let me draw sample variance
we're going to take the weighted the
weighted sum of the squared differences
from the mean and divide by this minus 1
so we can get the best estimator of the
true variance so it's 1 x 1 x or let me
write know let's the other way actually
around we have 142 samples that were 1
minus 0.5 6-8 away from the actual form
our sample mean so these are the we're
this far from the sample mean 142 times
we're going to square those distances
plus the other 108 times the other 108
times we got a 0 so we were 0 minus
0.568 away from the sample mean and then
we are going to divide that by we're
going to divide that by the total number
of samples minus 1 this is that minus 1
is our adjuster so that we don't we
don't underestimate
so 250 -1 let's get our calculator out
again and get our calculator out and so
we have 100 we put a parenthesis around
everything I have 142 x times 1 minus
0.5 6 8 squared plus 108 times 108 times
0 minus and you could obviously do parts
of this in your head but I'm just going
to write the whole thing out there -
0.568 squared squared and then all of
that divided by 250 minus 1 is 249 so
our sample variance is well just say
point 2 4 6 it is equal to it is our
sample variance our sample I'll write it
over here our sample variance sample
variance is equal to zero point two four
six if you were to take the square root
of that our actual sample standard
deviation our stats sample standard
deviation is going to be let's take the
square root of that answer right over
there and we get 0.49 six is equal to
zero I'll just round that up to 0.5 0 so
that is our sample standard deviation
now
this interval let's think of it this way
we are we are sampling from some from
some sampling distribution of the sample
mean so it looks like this over here it
looks like that over there and it has
some mean it has some it has some mean
and so the mean of the sampling
distribution of the sample mean is
actually going to be the same thing as
this mean over here it's going to be the
same mean value which is the same thing
as our population proportion we've seen
this multiple times and this is the
sampling distributions standard
deviation so the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution so the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution so we could view that as
one standard deviation right over there
so the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution we've seen
multiple times is equal to the standard
deviation is equal to the standard
deviation let me do this in a different
color is equal to is equal to the
standard deviation of our original
population is equal to the original
standard deviation original population
divided by the square root of the number
of samples so divided by the square root
of the number of samples so this divided
by 250 now we do not know this right
over here we do not know the actual
standard deviation in our population but
our best estimate of that and that's
what we call it confident we're
confident that the real mean is going or
the real the real population proportion
is going to be in this interval but
we're not we're confident but we're not
100% sure because we're going to
estimate this over here and if we're
estimating this we're really estimating
that over there so if this can be
estimated is going to be estimated by
this sample standard deviation so this
is so we are so then we can say this is
going to be approximately or if we
didn't get a weird completely skewed
sample it actually might not even be
approximately if we just had a really
strange sample but maybe we should write
confident that confident confident that
we are confident that the standard
deviation of our sampling distribution
is going to be around is going to be
around instead of using this we can use
our standard deviation of our sample our
sample standard deviation so 0.5 oh
divided by the square root of 250 and
what's that going to be that is going to
be so we have this value right over here
actually I don't have to round it
divided by the square root square root
of 250 we get point 0 3 1 so this is
this is equal to point zero 3 1 over
here so that's one standard
daeviation now they want a 99%
confidence interval so the way I think
about it is is how many if I randomly if
I randomly pick a sample from the
sampling distribution
what's the 99% chance or how many if let
me let me think of it this way how many
standard deviations away from the mean
do we have to be that we can be 99%
confident that any sample from the
sampling distribution will be in that
interval so another way to think about
it think about how many standard
deviations we need to be away from the
mean so we're going to be a certain
number of standard deviations away from
the mean such that any sample any pot
any mean that we calculate that we
sample from here any any sample from
this distribution has a 99% chance of
being with plus or minus that many
standard deviation so it might be from
there to there so that's what we want we
want a 99% chance that if we pick a
sample from the sampling distribution of
the sample mean it will be within this
many standard deviations of the actual
mean and to figure that out let's look
at an actual Z table so we want 99%
confidence so another way to think about
it if we want 99% confidence if we just
look at the upper half if we look at the
upper half right over here that orange
area should be 0.475 because if this is
0.475 then this other part is going to
be four point four seven five and we
will get to our sorry we want to get to
99 percent so it's not going to be 0.475
we have we're going to have to go to 0.4
we're gonna have to go to 0.49 five if
we want 99% confidence so this area has
to be 0.49 five over here because if
that is that over here we'll also be so
that their sum will be 99 percent of the
area now this is 0.49 five this value on
the z table right here will have to be
0.5 because all of this area if you
include all of this is going to be 0.5
so it's going to be 0.5 plus 0.4 9/5
it's going to be 0.9 it is going to be
0.9
9.99 five let me make sure I got that
right point nine nine five and so let's
look at our Z table so where do we get
point nine nine five on our Z table 0.99
0.995 is pretty close just to have a
little error it will be right over here
this is point nine nine five one so
another way to think about it is 99 so
this this value right here gives us the
whole cumulative area up to that up to
our mean so if you look at the entire
distribution like this if you look at
the entire distribution this is the mean
right over here this tells us that at
2.5 standard deviations above the mean
so this is 2.5 standard deviations above
the mean so this is 2.5 times the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution if you look at this whole
area this whole area over here if you
look at the Z table is going to be 0.995
1 which tells us just this area just
this area right over here is going to be
0.49 5-1 which tells us this area plus a
symmetric area of that many standard
deviations below the mean if you combine
them 0.495
1 times 2 gets us to 99 point 2 so this
whole area right here is 99.99 2 so if
we look at the area 2.5 standard
deviations above and below the mean
above and below the mean let me be
careful this isn't just 2.5 we have to
add another digit of precision this is
2.5 and the next digit of precision is
given by this column over here so we
have to look all the way up into the
second-to-last column and we have to add
a digit of 8 here so this is 0.2 this is
two point five eight standard deviations
two point five we have two point five
over here and then we get the next digit
eight from the column two point five
eight standard deviations above and
below the standard deviation encompasses
a little over 99% of the two
probability so there's a little over 99%
chance that any sample mean that I
select from the sampling distribution of
the sample mean will fall within this
much of the standard deviation so let me
put it this way there is a there is a 99
there is a 99 it's actually what a
ninety-nine point two percent chance
right if you multiply this time so you
get 0.99 you get 0.99 actually you this
you get 0.99 Oh two so we'll say roughly
well say roughly 99% chance 99% chance
that any sample that a random a random a
random sample mean is within two point
five eight two point eight five eight
standard deviations of the sampling mean
of of our population me of our of the
the mean of the sampling distribution of
the sampling mean which is the same
thing as our actual population mean
which is the same thing as our
population proportion so of P and we
know what this value is right here at
least we have a decent estimate for this
value we don't know exactly what this is
but our best estimate for this value is
this over here this over here so we
could rewrite this and we could say that
we are confident we are confident
because we're all really using an
estimator to get this value or here we
are confident that there is a 99% chance
chance that a random X a random sample
mean is within and let's figure out this
value right here using a calculator so
it is 2.5 eight times our best estimate
of the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution so times 0.03 one
is equal to point
oh well let's just round this up because
it's so close to 0.08 is within 0.08 is
within point zero point oh eight
of the population of the population
proportion or you could say that you're
confident that the population proportion
is within 0.08 of your sample mean right
that's the exact same suggest the exact
same statement so if we want our
confidence interval our actual our
actual number that we got for there are
actual sample mean we got was 0.568
0.568 so we could replace this and
actually let me do it I can delete this
right here let me clear it I can replace
this because we actually did take a
sample so I can replace this with 0.568
so we could be confident that 99 that
there's a 99% chance that 0.568 is
within 0.08 of the actual sample of the
population proportion which is the same
thing as the population mean which is
the same thing as the mean of the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
so forth and so on and just to make it
clear we can actually swap these two it
wouldn't change the meaning if this is
within point O eight of that then that
is within point eight eight of this so
let me switch this up a little bit so we
can put a p is within of of let me
switch this up of 0.568 and now
linguistically it sounds a little bit
more like a confidence interval we are
confident that there's a 99% chance that
p is within 0.08 of the sample mean of
0.568 so what would be our confidence
interval it would be 0.568 0.568 plus or
minus 0.08 and what would that be if you
add point oh eight to this right over
here at the upper end you're going to
have you're going to have point six four
eight and at the lower end of our range
so this is going to be this is the upper
end the lower end if we subtract eight
from this we get point four eight eight
so we are 99% confident that the true
population proportion is between these
two numbers or another way that the true
percentage of teachers who think those
computers or good ideas is between where
99% confident where
that night there's a 99% chance that the
true percentage of teachers that like
the computers is between forty eight
point eight percent and sixty four point
eight percent now that we answered the
first part of the question the second
part how could the survey be changed to
narrow the confidence interval but to
maintain the 99% confidence interval
well you could just take more samples if
you take more samples than our estimate
then our estimate of this of the
standard deviation of this distribution
will go down because this denominator
will be higher if that denominator is
higher then this whole thing will go
down so if the standard deviations go
down here then when we count the
standard deviations when we do the plus
or minus on the range this value will go
down and we'll narrow our range so you
just take more samples